انطلق في الدوحه منتدى الامن العالمي لعام
ويناقش اعاده تشكيل النظام العالمي سيركز
المنتدى على النهج الدولي لاداره الصراعات
والازمات والتعاون وسيشمل مناقشات حول
مواضيع مثل ازمه الطاقه العالميه ونهج
تعزيز الاقتصادات المستدامه وتنافس القوى
العظمى التي شكلت الحرب والحرب في
اوكرانيا ذروته وكذلك سيناقش دور مجلس
الامن التابعي للامم المتحده
وقد اكد الشيخ محمد بن عبد الرحمن الثاني
رئيس الوزراء وزير الخارجيه القطري على
استمرار دوله قطر في نهجها القائم على
جهود الوساطه لتسويه النزاعات الدوليه
بطرق السلميه واكد في افتتاح منتدى الامن
العالمي على ان قطر اصبحت شريكا يعتد به
في صناعه السلام
اتخذت دوله قطر النهج القائم على التركيز
على التنميه الوطنيه والتنميه الانسانيه
داخليا وعلى السياسه الخارجيه القائمه على
الموازنه بين المصالح والمبادئ والوساطه
في حل النزاعات بالطرق السلميه وبينما
نمضي بثبات نحو تحقيق غايات رؤيه قطر
الوطنيه
2030 في كل المجالات تبرز جهود الوساطه
التي اقدمنا عليها في نزع فتيل الازمات
وتسويه المنازعات في كل من دارفور ولبنان
وافغانستان وتشاد وغيرها لقد اصبحت قطر
استنادا الى هذا النهج الفريد شريكا يعتد
به في صناعه السلام ودعم الاستقرار
وسنواصل هذا الدور الفاعل في منطقتنا وعلى
مستوى العالم للتخفيف من حده الازمات
الاقليميه والدوليه واستجابه للتحديات
الراهنه وتاكيدا على اهميه ايجاد الحلول
السلميه للنزاعات من خلال الحوار
والدبلوماسيه
من مقر المنتدى في الدوحه ينضم الينا
مراسلنا عدنان بوريني عدنان عناوين مهمه
خاصه في سياق الحرب الروسيه الاوكرانيه
وتداعيات الازمات والصراعات حول العالم ما
اتجاهات النقاشات داخل اروقه المنتدى
نعم سلمى هي اذا النسخه خامسه من هذا
المنتدى تكتسب اهميتها الكبيره من السياق
الذي يعيشه العالم الذي نشهده في نشرات
الاخبار يوميا نتحدث عن سياق متفاقم عن
كثير من النزاعات المتصاعده عن حرب
اوكرانيا عن النزاع المتصاعد في شرق اسيا
ازمات الطاقه القاره الافريقيه وغيرها
لذلك
اختائمون على
منتدعم شعار اعاده رسم ملامح النظام
العالمي والحديث عن النزاعات والتعاون في
التصدي او في سياق التصدي لهذه المساحه
نتحدث عن مجموعه كبيره من المشاركين نتحدث
عن رؤساء حكومات وزراء رؤساء قطاعات امنيه
الكثير الكثير من المشاركين الذين
سيناقشون بالتفصيل على مدار ثلاثه ايام كل
هذه الموضوعات كما ذكرت سلمى اولى الكلمات
هذا اليوم عفوا سلمى اولى الكلمات خلال
هذا اليوم كانت لرئيس الوزراء القطري
الشيخ محمد بن عبد الرحمن الثاني الذي
تحدث بوضوح عن الدور الذي تلعبه دوله قطر
في استقرار اسواق الطاقه في ظل هذه
النزاعات التي باتت تؤثر عليه بشكل واضح
تتحدث ايضا عن دور قطر في صناعه الاستقرار
والسلام العالميين الذي لعبته في اكثر من
مكان تحدث اقليميا عن اهميه الحوار في
بناء الاستقرار اكثر في مساحه الاقليم هنا
سلمى نتحدث عن جلسات متتابعه بعد قليل
ستكون هناك جلسه حول اوكرانيا الحدث الذي
بلا شك باتا يعيد رسم كثير من الاشياء
عالميا الكثير من الاراء ستطرح وستناقش
حول مستقبل العالم وانعكاسات هذه النزاعات
شكرا لك من مقر المنتدى في الدوحه مراسلنا
عدنان بوريني